[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv
soixante dix huit pour un nouveau numéro
du 7 8 sociétés votre rendez vous
hebdomadaire où l'on discute des sujets
qui font l'actualité
selon l'organisation mondiale de la
santé un pays sur trois en europe a vu
ses services de lutte contre le cancer
partiellement ou complètement perturbé
par la pandémie 30me cancers seraient
non détectée selon la ligue contre le
cancer alors à la veille d'octobre rose
ont fait le point sur la question du
cancer du sein avec nos invités ce soir
de docteur catherine painset bonsoir mon
sens vous êtes médecin coordonnateur
pour les yvelines du centre régional de
coordination des dépistages des cancers
d'ile-de-france et docteur bernard guyot
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le chef
allez-y
je suis responsable du pôle femme mère
enfant à l'hôpital de poissy saint
germain en laye et en fait mon activité
de l'activité de chirurgie oncologique
et je n'occupe pas en particulier des
cancers gynécologiques et les cancers du
sein avec toute une équipe bien
évidemment et donc justement le cancer
du sein chaque année dans les yvelines
quarante mille dépistages sont organisés
catherine vince les est ce que c'est un
chiffre qui est toujours d'actualité
absolument et je dirais même que sur les
derniers mois c'est un chiffre qui est
même presque à la hausse puisqu'on a été
vraiment dans une situation de
rattrapage des dépistages qui
malheureusement ont eu un coup de frein
voire même un coup d'arrêt au moment de
la pandémie et de la première vague de
qu'ovide on a dû arrêter les activités
de dépistage pendant environ une dizaine
de semaines mais dès qu'elles ont pu
reprendre et dans les conditions
sanitaires respecter en respectant les
gestes barrière à ce moment là et encore
maintenant aujourd'hui bien évidemment
dès le mois de juillet l'année dernière
dès 2020 on a été dans une suractivité
de dépistage permettant un rattrapage et
fin d'année 2020 on assure la région
ile-de-france fait environ 92% des
dépistages qu'on attendait alors qu'on
avait eu au mois de mars tout un art et
puis ensuite jusqu'en juillet on était
en dessous niveau dépistage habituel
mais dès le mois de juillet on était
vraiment totalement au dessus est
vraiment les cabinets de radiologie et
puis surtout toute la sensibilisation
qui a pu être fait vis-à-vis des femmes
pour ray pour leur répéter quelque part
leur redonner confiance aussi pour
retourner vers le système de soins dans
des conditions de sécurité optimales et
surtout pour ne pas perdre la chance
quelque part que leur offre ce dépistage
en matière de dépistage précoce bernard
guyot le cancer du sein est la première
cause de décès chez les femmes mais
est-ce qu'on peut rappeler aussi le taux
de guérison
le cancer du sein est un cancer fréquent
chez les femmes mais dans les cancers
qui est celui qui a parmi les meilleurs
résultats thérapeutiques
on peut considérer que on à 81 88 % de
survie à 5 ans dans les cancers du sein
et les progrès de dans les guérisons
augmentent de plus d'1 % tous les ans
donc les ya des progrès thérapeutiques
vraiment presque constant tous les ans
et c'est très satisfaisant parce que
même si l'incidence augmente on a des
résultats thérapeutiques y compris dans
les formes les plus graves de cancers du
sein est une maladie très hétérogène il
ya des formes très anodines et défendent
très grave des cancers du sein est
vraiment il ya des progrès
thérapeutiques
qui sont belles certains d'entre eux le
prêtre est notable alors la crise de la
commune n'a pas empêché certaines de
découvrir à cette maladie je vous
propose qu'on écoute et miner le bras
cette yvelinoise est diagnostiqué en mai
2000 20 elle nous raconte son parcours
[Musique]
n'a pas eu de dépistage c'est juste que
j'ai senti une boucle sur vingt cinq ans
j'ai pris ma douche
tout simplement et à partir de là j'ai
vu mon médecin parce que j'avais dans
avant j'avais eu des kystes donc je le
pensais que c'était un simple qui
c'est un peu le monde qui s'écroule
surtout qu'à 36 ans on pense pas avoir
un cancer
j'ai tout de suite pensé à mes enfants
c'était très compliqué et puis après on
fait avec puis montez pas quoi
que c'était très angoissant c'était
surtout le fait que tous les examens
toutes les consultations tous les
traitements se sont fait j'étais tout
seul ça n'allait pas attendre parce que
j'étais vraiment déjà un stade un peu
limite donc ça aurait pu être plus
compliquée encore le traitement et j'ai
quand même des enfants qui sont reste
jeune et du coup je voulais voilà donc
battre pour eux pour moi pour ma famille
quoi
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais bien je suis en
rémission du coup depuis y ait le moins
de mix
quasiment un an jour pour jour la
découverte
je suis encore en traitement un
traitement c'est l'hormonothérapie
c'est encore plus important parce que
c'est vrai que beaucoup d'idées reçues
est ce vraiment que le cancer du sein en
arrive après 50 ans alors qu'il ya de
plus en plus de cancers du sang qui
arrive avant 40 ans et du coup il faut
vraiment penser voilà ce pse ne touchez
pas avant de de se toucher pendant la
douche
regardez si mon sens pas une bulle au
niveau du sein parce que les bains ça
peut vous sauver la vie
bernard guyot je vous ai vu acquiescé
quand emilie de brady que ça touche
aussi des personnes jeunes elle a une
trentaine d'années
alors que les crips ionel chez les
personnes de moins de 25 ans mais on
peut avoir chaque année nous avons des
très jeunes patientes souvent des formes
familiales d'ailleurs quand les patients
de moins 35 ans des cancers du sein il
ya une enquête génétique et fait
bénéficier nez et mis dans la boucle
pour lancer une enquête génétique et
rechercher des prédispositions
familiales qui pourrait avoir des
conséquences très très importante pour
le reste de la famille et de la fratrie
et les parents et donc effectivement on
pense surtout au cancer du sein après 50
ans que dépistage de masse tous les deux
ans jusqu'à 74 ans mais il ya aussi
venir près d'un quart des cancers du
sein qui surviennent avant 50 ans ils
sont souvent des formes plus agressives
que les fans veulent
pas d'un seul et
pourtant si le mot est le bon le
dépistage national commence pour les
femmes de 50 ans à partir de 50 ans le
dépistage par mammographie effectivement
systématique et proposer aux femmes à
partir de 50 ans de manière donc
générale sur l'ensemble de la population
mais il faut bien insister sur le fait
qu'on recommande à toute femme dès l'âge
de 25 ans d'avoir un suivi ces no logic
s'agit d'écologie qu est globalement qui
donc concerne également la vision c'est
nos logiques de façon à justement évalué
le risque de la femme aussi puisque
comme l'a dit bernard guyot il ya aussi
un risque familiale éventuels qui peut
entraîner des des examens beaucoup plus
tôt que l'âge de 50 ans et donc tout
cela est à évaluer avec son médecin
traitant avec son gynécologue ou avec sa
sage femme de façon à
faire un dépistage qui soit adaptée à
son risque individuel si on propose le
dépistage à partir de 50 ans en matière
organisé c'est qu'effectivement comme
l'a dit également le docteur guyot c'est
à partir de cet âge là qu'on a quand
même une augmentation très significative
du risque de cancer qui augmente
d'ailleurs avec l'avancée en âge et donc
à partir de cet âge là il est justifié
de le faire rêver lmnp tous les deux ans
pour l'ensemble de la population et je
leur dis si on est vraiment sur un
niveau de risque supérieure liées à ses
antécédents familiaux il ya des
dépistages personnalisé à envisager à la
fois plus tôt mais également avec une
fréquence différente en matière de
dépistage mammographique vous parliez
tout à l'heure que les chiffres pour
l'année 2000 21 2020-2021 seront plutôt
bon mais entre 2019 et 2020 il ya quand
même une grosse différence dans les
yvelines 39% des femmes concernées
s'étaient fait des pistes en 2019 ça
tombe à 35% pour l'un 2020 outre les
fermetures le premier confinement qui a
tout mis à l'arrêt ce qu'il ya aussi de
l'inquiétude alors il ya certainement
aussi de l'inquiétude des femmes pour
retourner vers les centres de les
centres de radiologie mais comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure c'est vrai
qu'il ya une très nette augmentation
d'une reprise de l'activité de dépistage
qui a été majeur en fin d'année et alors
c'est vrai que là vous avez sorti des
chiffres sur une année c'est vrai aussi
que nous on raisonne sur deux ans et que
globalement je pense que sur l'année
2020 2021 début 2021 on était aussi
encore en rattrapage de la situation
précédente et que globalement sur une
campagne de deux ans on va être très peu
en baisse sur malgré la crise du coville
est aujourd'hui il ya une activité au
niveau des centres de radiologie qui est
tout à fait normal par rapport à ce
qu'on a l'habitude d'avoir dans le cadre
du dépistage organisé docteur guyot est
ce qu'au sein du chips le centre
hospitalier poissy saint germain on a vu
des femmes arrivées avec un dépistage
tardif
l'an dernier ça a été vraiment très très
compliqué
à cause des gamins qui était très très
compliqué les gens pouvaient plus sortir
on était à kilomètres de chez soi et
alors nous avons l'an dernier pendant
deux mois transformé le secteur de
réveil chirurgicale de l'hôpital de
poissy et mantes en réanimation
satisfait que nous avons pu quand même
opérer tous les cancers du sein avec un
décalage de quelques jours en
sanctuarisant le blog de l'hôpital de
meulan qui fait partie de notre groupe
hospitalier de territoire et nous avons
enterré c'était très sympa d'ailleurs de
pouvoir enterrer les malades là bas ils
peuvent perdre de temps on a décalé les
interventions que de quelques jours et
nous avons pu ne pas perdre de temps
dans les prises en charge des cancers
diagnostiqués après il ya eu
effectivement décalage pendant deux mois
des personnes qui n'ont pas pu l'avoir
d'examen effectivement comme dit le dr
vince t on est en train de rattraper
avec tous les centres de radiologie qui
fonctionne dans les yvelines pour
justement de reprendre les patients s'en
charger il ya une reprise de confiance
s'est faite sur le dépistage mais l'an
dernier pendant trois quatre mois il ya
eu effectivement un creux dans les dents
les prises en charge moi j'ai eu
l'impression d'avoir un peu plus de
cancers du sein localement avancé avec
des attaques ganglionnaire donc des
formes plus grave de cancer du sein que
les cancers
locaux petit nom palpable qu'on a très
souvent avec le dépistage aux recettes
de meilleurs pronostics où on peut faire
de la chirurgie ambulatoire de façon
très importante en dédramatisant les
prisons sable non vernis a vu vraiment
je dirais 4 5 mois de de flottement dans
le dans le dépistage et la prise en
charge a été compliqué pour les pour les
patients pour les personnes pour les
familles là on est en train de de
revenir sur une vitesse de croisière
plutôt normal dans les prisons saint
chaque semaine
chaque semaine nous interrogeons nous
téléspectateurs avec une question en
lien avec la thématique cette semaine
nous ont répondu à l'affirmative pour
61% d'entre eux que là crise sanitaire
arrête à retarder leurs examens médicaux
docteur guyot un retard de prise en
charge sur un cancer du sein qu'elle
peut être l'impact alors le problème du
retard c'est un cancer du sang qui est
en général qui est pas une maladie les
volumes sur la plupart des cancers du
sein il ya des coins perdus ou
un retard de 1 mois et demi à deux mois
le correspondre à une atteinte
ganglionnaire et l'atteinte d'un
millionnaire du croate khider dans le
cancer du sein correspond à une forme
plus grave il valait précisé d'emblée
très souvent de la chimiothérapie avant
la chirurgie avec des conséquences
thérapeutique moins bonne en face les
concerts plus difficiles à traiter donc
en l'espace de deux mois de retard de
prise en charge on peut avoir une
patiente sûre difficile d'avoir une
atteinte ganglionnaire et ça change tout
en termes de l'an termes de pronostic
donc le diagnostic en 3d patiente soit
les guides pour les pour les prises en
charge parce qu'après il ya toute une
coordination des soins qui se fait à
partir du diagnostic trouver une plage
au bloc les réunions de concertation
pluridisciplinaires ou éventuellement
avoir un avis d'oncologie pour fait
intime aux thérapies mais avant là
surgit et tout ça le nécessitant fait
une bonne organisation dans le temps
pour effectivement que les trois corps
d'homme sans perdre de temps
l'an dernier des chercheurs de
l'institut contre le cancer gustave
roussy chronique les retards de prise en
charge cause sur cinq ans une mortalité
de 2% c'est un avis que vous partagez
qui a pu être attrapé alors rattrapé
c'est si compliqué de le dire puisque
comme on vous l'a dit et comme le
docteur d'un an guyot le dis il ya eu un
retard forcément au moment de la
première vague qu'ovide qui a entraîné
un arrêt des dépistages et forcément il
ya il y aura un impact c'est clair
aujourd'hui cet impact en termes de
mortalité on ne peut pas le mesurer tout
ce qu'on sait et par rapport à toutes
ces analyses sont sur des données
rétrospectives des méta-analyses qu'ont
pu être fait qui effectivement montre
qu'il ya au-delà d'un seuil un temps de
retard de la chirurgie des conséquences
en terme de mortalité donc oui
malheureusement il ya il ya eu des
pertes de chance dans cette période là
et c'était c'est bien pour ça qu'il ya
une importance de re sensibiliser les
gens sur retournez vous faire dépister
si vous ne l'avez pas fait n'ayez pas
peur aujourd'hui de franchir la porte
d'un cabinet de radiologie il faut
absolument faire ce dépistage de manière
régulière tous les deux ans pour
justement repérer des tumeurs à un stade
précoce de façon à ce que la prise en
charge soit la plus optimale possible et
de fait réduire le risque de mortalité à
long terme donc forcément il ya un léger
sur iis mais aujourd'hui on n'est pas
encore capable on n'a pas le recul bien
évidemment pour évaluer cette
conséquence en terme de mortalité ont
conduire à des études mais on avait
besoin aussi d'avoir un peu plus de
recul pour connaître les stades au
diagnostic il faut avoir un effectif qui
reste suffisamment grands aussi donc on
conduit ça on va conduire cela au niveau
de notre région ile de france notamment
sur les bases qu'on a au niveau des
desserts cdc pour mesurer effectivement
si on a eu des tumeurs plus grande entre
guillemets après l'émoi qu'ovide que ce
qu'on a l'habitude d'avoir dans le cadre
du dépistage organisé dr guyot vous
parlez d'un flottement pendant plusieurs
mois chaque année les chips accueille
environ 250 nouveaux cas est ce que vous
avez des patientes qui ont arrêté leur
traitement de peur de revenir à
l'hôpital d'avec la crise non non pas du
tout c'est un peu sur le suivi ou les
personnes en les patientes ont préféré
décaler les consultations on accueille
des consultations de surveillance par
vidéo consultation les patients à haut
risque on leur a conseillé de décaler
leur rendez vous de passer la phase la
plus grave on a modifié un peu les
prises en charge pour les pour les
légions en tissu on a décalé les
traitements on a préféré faire de la
chirurgie première que des signaux
première pour ne pas fragiliser les
patientes et risqués qu'elles fassent le
cosy dans l'étang immunodéprimées on a
eu des traitements hormonaux premier
avant la chirurgie pour ne pas avoir des
patients qui est le coville est soit
opéré
l'ex général et fasse des copines grave
du fait de la chirurgie c'était
compliqué c'est ça que j'appelle un
flottement t on a été obligés d'adapter
nos pratiques et de de faire un petit
peu différemment bien évidemment c'était
une concertation au niveau de l'inca et
de nos collègues des sons de lutte
contre le cancer avec lesquels nous
travaillons en partenariat nous nous
sommes un centre spécialisé mais notre
centre de référente et n'anticipe
lauréate à toulouse qui est aussi le le
service univers critère de rattachement
de l'université versailles saint quentin
dont nous sommes à des services de
partenaires en fait
madame ainsley octobre rose va bientôt
commencer c'est à ce moment là qu'on
parle le plus du cancer du sein même si
c'est toute l'année le dépistage 2020
beaucoup de choses ont été annulés
décalé est ce que cette année vous allez
pouvoir sensibiliser comme les années
précédentes
tout à fait il ya un très gros programme
pour les personnes en charge justement
de l'information de la prévention de la
sensibilisation autour de ce dépistage
tout au long de ce mois d'octobre mais
vous avez aussi raison de le dire
octobre rose c'est très bien ça permet
ça fait un grand flash quelque part sur
cette promotion du dépistage mais faut
vraiment insisté sur le fait que le
dépistage c'est tout au long de l'année
et qu' il ne faut pas penser à ses seins
si je puis dire qu'au cours du mois
d'octobre mais véritablement tout au
long de sa vie je dirais et donc par
définition tout au long de l'année à
chaque fois qu'on va chez le médecin on
a une question une interrogation docteur
guyot aussi j'imagine on sensibilise
toujours
à écouter c'est une partie de mon
activité je fais partie des fondateurs
de la dni ça va faire bientôt 17 ans
cette année et suivis je suis très
sensibilisé notre équipe aussi et deux
infirmières et les infirmières
d'annoncer les oncologues donc nous on
essaye de d'envoyer de donner les
messages de faire parler plâtre est un
peu un petit peu notre notre coeur de
métier notre sensibilité un
jeu sans permettre ajouté c'est aussi
voilà une femme dès qu'elles voient un
signe d' alerte dès qu'elles sont
quelque chose qu'elle voit une anomalie
au niveau de ses seins il faut
absolument qu'elle ait consulté
quel que soit quel que soit son âge pour
avoir l'avis de son médecin donc c'est
faux pas être obsessionnel bien
évidemment sur la probabilité d'avoir un
cancer etc faut vivre sereinement mais
néanmoins est acteur soi même de son
dépistage et ça c'est entre guillemets
au quotidien mais voilà c'est important
et puis le dépistage mammographique tous
les deux ans à partir de 50 ans ml le
bras le disait bien il faut aussi
s'écouter je vous propose qu'on s'arrête
sur ces mots là c'est la fin de ce sept
huit sociétés merci de nous avoir suivis
octobre rose débute le 1er octobre
prochain se tiendra jusqu'au 31 du même
mois la semaine prochaine un nouveau
moment des changes on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine prenez soin de vous
[Musique]